[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raconte moi quand tu étais mon pays que
j'aime à dire eh bien vous vais te
raconter l'histoire du côté poisson de
grande yaka nuit je me dis pas ce que je
ferai ce que je m'ennuie appartement de
petits poissons tu sais bien ce grand
bocal ça m'amuse de voir et j'ai chuté
trop croyez que je vais le chercher
[Musique]
par exemple comment il a dit oui et bien
léché
je le vois h x p tit il est si petit il
ya du chef chantier et puis mes fringues
aka et j'ai rompu
il n'a pas dû aller bien loin des phases
où je vais le chercher
[Musique]
non mais le bon par e mail en croit pas
demander des bonbons marque à la
produire à qui tu raques et le faire le
petit poisson du cran qui a disparu
regarde le bo qualifie d' on m'en parle
de l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps des bordures les pattes ton pote
de boitsfort
il était là ce matin et il est ici bien
à à mon cher situé chemin
aide moi elle retrouvait pourtant sympa
monstre va le rattraper ton petit
poisson hoyaux pas d'odeur de poissons
et pas deux gouttes d'eau par ici berry
miss bérénice c'est what it is khan
dérange-t-il bonnes questions seulement
tu n'as pas vu pas fait un poisson par
là par hasard dispositif si vous avez
apprécié entre neuf et dix questions
stupides
elle a raison le poisson n'est pas parti
tout seul
quelqu'un a dû emporter quelqu'un qui
aime le poisson d une idée qu'il avait
trouvé l'armateur de bras font alors
mettre en accord
il me semble que vous avez des ennuis ya
de drôles de bruits logo votre sac à
malices tu aurais dû bouffer
mais très bien et fait même cas vous
avez là dedans petit poisson qui n'est
pas à nous mais voilà sa peau qui va
servir de local à les mettre mal car
pensez vous videz votre poste jusqu'à la
dernière goutte de sang ce petit poisson
chat c'est parce que je le sois titus
alors j'ai vu de l'eau gelée but et ce
petit poisson était cachée au fond je ne
dirai rien tu as many revenais pas il
est parti ils ont fait honte au titisee
tuner tv
[Applaudissements]
regardez la marinade et mandy poissant
bien-aimé e
mon petit poisson position donnée mais
ce petit poisson pour des boissons
je crois bien qu'il était mieux dans le
jet d'eau neil gore et après après et du
notw
[Applaudissements]